A CORVETTE STINGRAY,
MERCEDES-BENZ AND A JAGUAR.
VALUED AT MORE THAN A MILLION
DOLLARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S NEW TARIFFS ON
FOREIGN-MADE WASHING MACHINES IS
PUTTING ONE TENNESSEE COMMUNITY
IN A TOUGH SPOT.
STEVE HARRIGAN TELLS US WHY FROM
KNOXVILLE, TENNESSEE, .
-- CLARKSVILLE.
>> WASHING MACHINES PROVIDE AN
EARLY TEST TO BRING BACK
MANUFACTURING JOBS TO THE U.S.
A NEW TARIFFS’S LAPSE OF
FOREIGN-MADE MACHINES WITH
ATTACKS.
SUPPORTERS OF THE TARIFFS SAY
IT’S NECESSARY TO PROTECT U.S.
FIRMS AGAINST UNFAIR TRADE
PRACTICES.
>> BRING IN A WASHER THAT
BASICALLY WAS MADE OVERSEAS AND
YOU ADD A FEW NUTS AND BOLTS
HERE IN AMERICA AND CALLED IT
MADE IN THE USA.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
>> OPPONENTS SAY IT WILL SERVE
TO KEEP OUTDATED COMPANIES
AFLOAT.
>> IT’S UNFORTUNATE THAT CERTAIN
MANUFACTURERS WHO SEEM UNABLE TO
COMPETE IN THE MARKETPLACE
TURNED INTO THESE TRADE EFFORTS
HAS A WAY TO TRY TO COMPETE.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS
AGGRESSIVELY PITCHED THE U.S. IS
A GREAT INVESTMENT FOR FOREIGN
MANUFACTURERS.
>> THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A BETTER
TIME TO HIRE, BUILD, INVEST,
GROW IN THE UNITED STATES.
AMERICA IS OPEN FOR BUSINESS.
>> IN CLARKSVILLE, TENNESSEE,
LOCAL OFFICIALS SAY THE FACTS
ARE OTHERWISE.
THE NEW TARIFFS THREATENS A
SOUTH KOREAN ALGAE STATE OF THE
ART WASHING MACHINE FACTORY
UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID
WANT TO BRING JOBS BACK TO
AMERICA AND THAT’S WHAT WE ARE
DOING, BRINGING JOBS TO AMERICA.
IT’S KIND OF GOING TOTALLY
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THE MESSAGE HAS
BEEN.
>> LG SAYS THE TARIFF WILL FORCE
IT TO RAISE PRICES ON WASHING
MACHINES.
THEY ARE WORKING DOUBLE SHIFTS
TO TRY TO FINISH THE FACTORY AS